what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we cover the most powerful characters in
comics and today we're talking about a
character that i honestly cannot believe
we have not covered on this series
before the century now this century was
created by paul jenkins and jay lee and
first appeared in the century number one
published in the year 2000 as part of
marvel's marvel knights initiative which
was basically when marvel was trying to
recover from filing bankruptcy so they
started telling more mature storylines
with their characters but had it
published by jimmy palmiotti and joe
casada's event publications because it
was cheaper but the sentry was
introduced to be a superman analog in
the marvel universe and while he is by
no means the only superman knockoff that
marvel has created he's probably the
most popular and well received among
fans although i would argue that either
adam beshear or hyperion from earth13034
might stand a better chance or might be
a little more popular and more
well-received regardless the century's
real name is robert reynolds and he was
a man who was given a serum that gave
him the power of a million exploding
sons now as one does when they receive
such power reynolds begins a superhero
career as the century and becomes one of
the most famous superheroes in the world
now when we first see robert reynolds in
the comics however he's a middle-aged
and overweight man with no memories of
his superhero career now as robert's
memories begin to return he learns that
his arch-nemesis the void is returning
as well and he sets out to warn the
heroes of the marvel universe now upon
talking with the various marvel heroes
they began to remember the century as
pretty much all of them had worked
alongside him at one point or another
now as more and more people begin to
remember who this century is it becomes
clear why no one remembered him in the
first place because the sentry and the
void were merely two aspects of one
person and so to prevent the void from
destroying the earth robert reynolds had
a device installed on top of the
avengers tower which actually held the
century tower and used it to wipe the
minds of everyone on earth including
himself thinking that since the void
existed inside his mind if he erases
memory of the void the void would be
powerless now later the sentry would be
seen on the raft a prison for super
villains where he has voluntarily
committed himself for killing his wife
now after a prison break century fights
alongside the avengers and they soon
learned that robert reynolds was a virus
created by the evil mutant mastermind
and that virus is the reason that the
void exists within robert reynold's
brain it was written by brian michael
bendis yeah it was kind of stupid bear
with me here now after emma frost uses
her telepathic abilities to heal
century's brain including revealing that
he had not in fact murdered his wife he
joins the avengers and resumes his
career as a superhero now the source of
centuries powers are a little bit of a
gray area and what i mean is that there
have been different explanations given
in different comics for instance one
explanation of century's powers is that
they come from a modified version of the
super soldier serum that was used on
steve rogers and this modified version
is said to be a thousand times more
powerful than the original version now
according to another source the sentry
is actually an alien life force that
made its way to earth and found a host
within the super soldier serum that was
then administered to robert reynolds but
no matter which one of these versions is
true what cannot be denied is centuries
one of the most powerful heroes the
marvel universe has ever seen of course
sentry possesses superhuman strength and
is one of the strongest superheroes if
not the strongest he's capable of
sinking an island and carrying a shield
helicarrier although he did have help
from wonder man and carol danvers when
he was doing that the centuries proven
to be stronger than thor and the hulk
and was able to lift the dead body of a
celestial and fly it into space which is
crazy when you consider just how
absolutely massive celestials really are
now century was also able to rip carnage
apart with no difficulty and on another
occasion broke the axe of galactus
herald terrax which was capable of
destroying planets now in addition to
his immense strength sentry also
possesses super speed and is able to fly
from the earth to saturn in a matter of
moments now the sentry is also insanely
durable taking multiple punches from
world breaker hulk and surviving a
nuclear explosion at point-blank range
with basically no injuries and although
it is pretty much impossible to harm the
sentry when he does suffer damage he can
heal from that damage instantaneously
thanks to his regenerative healing
factor now this healing factor is
incredibly powerful as century has been
able to heal his body after it was
completely destroyed and he seems to be
incapable of killing himself as he once
tried to do so by flying into the sun
but even that didn't kill him and this
is not the only time the century has
come back to life after being killed so
it seems like century is effectively
immortal now the sentry is also able to
manipulate matter on a molecular level
and this appears to be the source of all
of his other powers as this is the basis
of how the super soldier serum works by
bending the sentry's molecules and
instant into the future for this reason
he's able to turn matter into basically
anything he wants and one time when the
void was controlling him the sentry was
able to manipulate the molecules within
the molecule man owen reese which is
absolutely insane because owen reese is
one of the three or four most powerful
characters in the marvel universe if you
don't count the cosmic abstracts now
because somebody down in the comments is
going to say it if we don't say anything
this was also like post-retcon molecule
man so yes he was weaker than he was in
like secret wars 2. we have to mention
that because someone will say something
about that and i would rather say it
before you do so that if you do say in
the comments section we can all laugh at
you and say rob already said that now as
if it weren't enough already the sentry
is also capable of absorbing and
manipulating vast quantities of energy
often to devastating effects in one
instance a fight between the century and
photon genus vel results in multiple
planets being destroyed by the energy
being expelled and these guys were not
even going all out this sentry is also
able to emit so much energy that the
absorbing man is not able to absorb it
all and it melts him with the power of a
million exploding suns now the more
energy the sentry absorbs the stronger
he becomes and is suggested there's no
limit to the amount of energy the sentry
can absorb which means that his power is
basically limitless as he's able to
absorb energy from practically any
source now the sentry is also a telepath
which explains how he was able to make
everyone forget that he existed in the
first place although that was also done
with help of a device and i should point
out that not only did century alter the
minds of every human on earth but he did
so to all the inhumans living on the
moon as well now in one of the weirdest
aspects of century's story he
subconsciously transfers his memories to
the mind of a comic book writer named
paul jenkins so paul jenkins century's
kind of a creator basically becomes a
character in the marvel universe that
writes comics about the century's
adventures since he can't remember them
it's weird it was brian michael bendis
and although he's not usually considered
one of marvel's strongest telepaths the
sentry was able to resist a mind spell
from doctor strange and it took emma
frost and charles xavier working
together to penetrate his mind and even
then century's able to block off things
he doesn't want them to see now there
are a litany of other powers the century
has like flight extremely acute senses
teleportation shape-shifting
invisibility intangibility and this has
been by no means an exhaustive list of
the various feats the centuries
performed because we could literally
just be here all night talking about
them because he is without a doubt one
of the most impressive characters in
marvel comics in terms of feats but
before we bring this video to a close i
do want to highlight a couple of his
most impressive feats starting with the
time that he and world breaker hulk
battle to a stalemate so if you're not
familiar world breaker hulk was at the
time the most powerful version of the
hulk that we had ever seen and he was
literally steamrolling over pretty much
every hero that got in his way finally
the century shows up and the two of them
fight with each of them expending so
much energy in the battle that they
start to revert back into their
respective alter egos and this was when
the century was in a weakened state so
if he had been at full strength there's
a good chance he would have beaten world
breaker hulk instead of just stalemating
him the second thing that i want to call
attention to is that according to peter
parker the century has also battled
galactus to a stalemate now this did
happen off panel but it did make it into
the official handbook of the marvel
universe so i think we could safely
accept it as canon and i'm sure most of
you guys realize how impressive it is
for any character to be able to battle
galactus one on one and survive much
less be able to stalemate this guy but
yeah this century is incredibly powerful
definitely beyond omega level and i
can't believe it's taken us so long to
cover him but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace